welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and she-hulk episode 4 has jennifer
walters looking to uh she-hulk smash by
going on a series of dates from hell i'm
so sorry jen tinder's the worst or
matcher biggest matcher in this universe
but one of those dates was a lot
creepier and suspicious than the rest
and yeah i'm talking about this weirdo
over here just who was that dude trying
so hard to get under she-hulk skin huh
and how could he be related to jen
getting jumped by the wrecking crew at
the end of episode 3. let us dive into
this potentially dangerous dating
dilemma my nerd babies because i'm
thinking that this guy is linked to one
of the incredible hulk's greatest
enemies but first do not forget to hit
up new rockstarsmerch.com to pick up our
newest latest obsession shirts inspired
by both she-hulk and house of the dragon
these shirts are amazing but are only
available for a limited amount of time
so pick them up today along with all of
our other dope nerd options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com alright guys we've
all gone on a bad tinder date or two
or three or five
thousand but never in my life have any
of my dates try to get me to give them
tips on how to best pierce my skin
that's weird in a red flag especially
right after i was just mugged by four
dudes who stole magic tools from
asgardian handyman something is up with
this man played by actor john bass who
in the credits of the early press
greener that we got is suspiciously
referred to as hulk todd but it looks
like marvel studios changed it to just
todd for the disney plus version i think
somebody messed up i think it's time we
took a stern look at this creepo because
anyone who calls you a specimen outside
of an apple store needs to be inspected
okay
i wish
specimen and by stern i mean stearns
because i think that this man is linked
to none other than the 2008 incredible
hulk's samuel stearns aka mr blue aka
the leader the man with the forehead
that you can see from the international
space station remember samuel stern that
weird nerd edward norton was texting
back and forth with to try to find a
cure for his big green ailment but
instead replicated bruce's blood enough
to fill an entire room with it and then
use some of that blood to turn emil
blonsky into the abomination yeah in the
comics that weirdo samuel has a brother
named philip stearns who also decides to
invest in the family business by
becoming the gamma-powered hulk villain
known as madman and that's who i believe
this hulk todd is supposed to be after
giving jen a fake name on his dating
profile how dare you lie on dating
profiles that's not allowed
but let's listen to what jen's obsessive
date says to her again shall we i was a
fan before we matched is it true are you
indestructible what about super speed
night vision impenetrable skin yeah my
skin is impenetrable even vibranium
why do you have some on you you want to
test it out no no no i wish like this
dude is absolutely consumed with the
idea of acquiring superpowers in
particular the concepts of
indestructibility and you know being
impenetrable and this sounds
suspiciously like madman philip stearns
in the comics who was super obsessed
with bruce banner's entire life even
before bruce became the incredible hulk
as both philip stearns and bruce banner
attended caltech in their nuclear
physics graduates program and philip
stearns was super jealous of bruce's
success especially when bruce got the
funding from the military to conduct the
gamma experiments that philip wanted to
do and extra especially when bruce got
turned into the super strong incredible
hulk as a result of those military
experiments with gamma radiation so this
being the case philip stearns would
spend years of his life trying to
replicate the conditions that turned
bruce banner into the incredible hulk
until he finally managed to turn himself
into a big red raging oak monstrosity
that adopted a separate and incredibly
mentally unstable persona that would be
known as madman however unfortunately
for philip stearns as much as he thought
that he could tame his own hulk beast
like roos he truly was not ready for how
strong madman actually was as madman
would end up completely taking over his
host mind by completely deleting the
original philip stern's persona from his
brain becoming madman through and
through like 100 madman all right gang
i've got two obsessions right now and
they're overlapping on one hand we got
she-hulk and on the other we've got
house of the dragon and you might think
that there's no common ground there but
you're wrong because both of these
latest obsessions are available at
epicuroshop.com
right now latest obsession number 19 is
lady justice and latest obsession number
20 is ash and ruin and they won't be
around forever so go get them before
they head on down to the dungeon to go
hang out with the theatrical release of
bad girl which we will never see and if
those teas aren't enough to wet your
targaryen whistle epic hero shop's fire
and blood collection will fit the bill
they've got the rogue prince for the
days that you're keyed up rums delight
for the days that you just want to
snuggle up with a dragon and king maker
for the days that you just gotta wear a
shirt with a bunch of dragons on it epic
hero shop.com is the place to get the
most up-to-date nerd merch and remember
in the first episode of she-hulk we
found out that captain america
they dropped this captain america shirt
immediately finally a way to celebrate
the long-awaited tapping of america's
ass and picking up a piece of epic hero
shop merch is the best way to support
the channel and it's so crazy cool and
amazing to see all of you guys repping
our merch we really truly appreciate the
support and it actually makes us feel
like rock stars when we see one of our
shirts out in the wild and be sure to
tag at epic hero shop and use the
hashtag real epic hero to get featured
on their page because they geek out as
much as we do in fact madman was so mad
that even the leader was scared of him
in the comics so scared in fact the
leader would actually forge a temporary
choose with his arch nemesis the hulk to
stop madman as the leader would use his
wumbo-sized cranium to accurately
predict the future that one day his
bully of a brother philip would come for
him and samuel stearns did not have the
strength to kill his own blood but
unfortunately the leader's prediction
would come true in the 2013 run of the
thunderbolts when the team would be
forced to fight this mad genius of a
madman and the leader would be forced to
blow his brother's head off of his body
by merely whispering a secret that mad
man's brain could not handle into his
ear super gnarly [ __ ] man it's pretty
pretty hardcore all this being said i
think that she helped episode four could
have just potentially lay the
foundations for mcu madman to appear by
the end of the series which is why i
believe this todd fellow is named hulk
todd in the credits and that it will be
revealed that this todd is actually
named philip stearns and that he is the
very entity that sends the goofy ass
wrecking crew to try to secure some of
jennifer walter's blood after seeing
just how much bruce's blood changed and
enhanced his own brother in the 2008
incredible hulk film because only a few
mere drops was enough to give samuel
stearns the cognitive ability to
calculate the future like some type of
human project insight from captain
america too and since she-hulk season 1
seems to be committed to continuing the
narrative of the 2008 hulk film through
the inclusion of mcu emil blonsky as a
main player as well as the show being
very much a story about family i can
easily see jen's creepy date todd having
ties to the stern family and his
brother's obsession with human-enhancing
hulk hemoglobin because with she-hulk
essentially being a spin-off of the hulk
i think it makes perfect sense to have a
spin-off of the hulk's nemesis teased in
2008 to be the main villain of the
series to remind audiences that the
leader is indeed still out there and
more than ready to menace the incredible
hulk as soon as the hulk's flight lands
from sakhar but that is who i believe
this mysterious todd hulk todd fellow is
but let us know what you guys think in
the comment section below but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you guys
want to see me tweet some really weird
[ __ ] and really fun theories but more
importantly you can follow new rockstars
wherever we are on social media and
please do not forget to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com today to pick up our
latest obsession shirts inspired by both
she-hulk and house of the dragon they're
super great super amazing and super
temporary so pick them up today but yes
thank you guys again for watching i love
you guys so much and you guys are
amazing please stay safe and i'll see
you guys next time
[Music]
you